[Music]
hi everyone I'm Ashley Carlson dr.
strange is coming home to the fans but
first let's check in with the Benedict's
and go deeper behind the scenes of this
mystical journey open your eye pretty
much all in the sequence where she opens
his mind to the multiverse that way I
found that profoundly moving that's a
hell of a task to set the visual effects
Department and for my money they
achieved it and it became more than just
a wham bam thank you ma'am distraction
or embellishment of a moment in a film
it became something profound in its own
right it's incredibly trippy and and
funny and weird but also really moving I
was like Scott Derrickson am I on drugs
I love this the best free ride any of us
will ever know what's in that tea
psilocybin LSD just tea
I think Scott's done such a fantastic
job I think he's definitely created this
world for us to be great to see where we
go forward with it now that we are
talking be in home release we can shock
secrets and spoilers we did get to see
that post-credit scene you kind of
getting to mix it up with Chris
Hemsworth as Thor were the inclusion
yeah what was that day like Chris is
lovely and that's a great character and
it was it was a lovely interaction and
you know there might be a little bit
more to see about and Thor yeah it's
only gonna say infinity war yes yeah Wow
yeah amazing it when's your first day
well I can neither Fung come on all
tonight what let's say hypothetically
you know long isn't it yeah just say we
can hypothetically speak on we get
hypothetical yeah um who would you want
to see him like the dynamic between two
characters who would you want to see him
mixing out well you know I mean being a
spider-man fan
I you know I'd like wrong in the
webslinger that we quite quite cool
I collected spider-man comics going up
as a kid and I'm a big kid now and to be
sort of invited into into a Marvel film
and to be a real part of this it's been
you know a spinning-wheel dream the
headlines are like they're benedict
cumberbatch replaced because they're
using like a standing because i guess
you're too busy yeah i think it's a bit
of an exaggeration I mean listen there's
great a great deal that can be done in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe we've had
and any any comic Universal we know from
whether it's hiding a pregnancy to
having someone there who's on another
side of the web there's only so much
they can do without you and so yeah I'll
be I'll be there don't worry yeah double
that scheduling is gotta be out of this
do you imagine I'm really not abusive of
the miracle workers little island is
it's an ever burgeoning cast as well
it's quite something but I've you know
my brother scripts and I've been reading
it it's very very good fun have a good
trip mr. strange
you